hey everyone Steve Weintraub with glider
uh here at the cinema center at marble
uh our studio I want to give a huge
thank you to everyone here for being
such an awesome partner
um at Tiff uh I am here with the film
The Producer and star and director of
Widow clico yeah I finally learned that
a little lesson before this yeah exactly
I practice about 29 times and I thought
I would mess up but I didn't
um first of all congratulations on your
movie and being part of the Toronto Film
Festival
um I wanna I hate doing the generic
thing up front but let's just get it
over with most people watching this will
have not seen the movie yet so who wants
to bite the bullet and describe the film
like you were talking to a friends and
family yeah so Widow picker is the story
of a young woman in France in 1799 who
is married to her husband she's in an
arranged marriage to her husband and and
and the film starts with the death of
the husband you know it's like Sunset
Boulevard it has a you know a body a
corpse and a funeral and it's
basically the film details the life that
they spent together building a Vineyard
learning how to make champagne at the
beginning of the champagne industry and
so one part of the film goes backwards
with their story showing their
relationship their marriage and how that
changes through time and the other part
of the film goes forward from the
funeral from the from the beginning and
tells how she takes the reins of the
company and becomes this incredible kind
of entrepreneur and force within wine
making and really invents modern
champagne as we know it today so she
she's an incredible figure in in French
culture in World culture
um and one of the first business women
in not only France but Europe but
uh I and I just I knew this woman holy I
read the book and it's uh based on the
best-selling
um New York Times best-selling book
biography called Widow clicko and
I could just relate so much with this
character and
I love acting I I feel like acting is
something that brings me closer to my
higher power and I think that that is
what
champagne making did or or the the
Alchemy of champagne making did for for
Cleco and
I think
you know to to discover your talent to
discover your purpose is something that
she did because she's she had gone
through this tragedy and had she not
gone through this tragedy it's just an
example of how adversity can really
sometimes shake you up and and wake you
up and and push you into doing something
you might not have done like standing in
the shadow of her husband
um so some really good things came from
well
this horrible tragedy which was her
finding her true self and
um and nurturing this passion and talent
so
yeah I I compare kind of my love for
like we all have our purpose and and
that was her purpose as I feel acting is
my purpose and so that gave me a very
strong kind of you want to protect the
thing that
is
uh vital
to to your existence and for that that
for her that was that was her art and
and the champagne is and and the wine
making is kind of a metaphor for
uh rather than it being a product
it was a metaphor for how this outlet
that she had could heal could regenerate
could restore like everything like most
creative process so it's it's a metaphor
for the creative process and how we can
heal through that act it's a spiritual
act how tough was it for you to tell
people um listen I'm gonna have to drink
a lot of champagne to get ready for this
role I gotta do some research how tough
was that for you to force yourself to
drink champagne
um well yeah I think it could be really
easy to fall into alcoholism and but
playing someone who um we have we
actually have really good friends who we
kind of we share a dear friend her name
is Souza and her daughter runs an
operation of wine making and uh it is
very impressive I find it very
impressive how they have to really hold
back from just getting tipsy all day
long that was um that was one of the
things that I think helped us ground it
um and and to kind of You're Sober yeah
that kind of helped us too I I don't
know what champagne tastes like anymore
but I think the um the wine making
process and the sort of the way
um people work on farms actually to make
wine was kind of an interesting way for
us to ground the project in in a way
based around work rather than the kind
of uh Salon life of French society at
that time time and and and where the
wine goes and what it means it was
actually kind of more based on people
that make something and crafts people
who make something with real as you know
Haley said with real passion and
integrity digging through you know get
shoveling manure and you know there's a
real gritty sense and feeling to the
film but also she was a genius
with marketing and in fact she invented
she was the first person to invent the
orange label on her because she she
smuggled wine she was a Smuggler as well
which was a really bold thing for a
woman to do at this time she could have
been hung if she were caught she would
have been in great big trouble but she
was moving she was shipping her wine
during the Napoleonic War across borders
to to amp through Amsterdam to get to
the tsar and experience loss and that
was devastating for her because this was
like her baby it's her creation but I
liked that she was kind of a criminal as
well and
um and so she and she invented you know
we
is a household name we all can recognize
the bottle but that was because of her
so when she shipped out her wine she
tied a tangerine ribbon around the neck
of the champagne so it would be
recognizable and this was her idea of
marketing yeah it's it's the more I
learned after seeing the movie The more
shocking it was that I didn't know
anything uh which is one listen I love
movies like that because it can shine a
light and make you want to read more
um but talk a little bit about for the
two of you was this a tough project to
like actually get off the ground and get
made or was it one of these things like
talk a little bit behind the scenes of
trying to get the financing and getting
it made
um so after I read the book and and I
knew that I had to will this film into
existence and it had to be made I could
see it I could smell it we could taste
it much like the the herself of Cleco
herself
um
so you know that kind of tenacity is
something that you need in this in this
industry specifically and then in any
industry as a woman to get a film made
especially pretty so we we had to work a
lot on the scripts to make it economical
um so we did that by um conceiving the
film in one location
um so that we could get the budgets down
to the film because there were previous
drafts of the script that uh she goes on
all of these Adventures but actually
what and I think that limitation allowed
us to it was it kind of set us free in
the sense that it decided for us what
kind of movie that this wanted to be
which really is a very intimate uh
portrayal and characterization of this
woman and I think that that kind of
really distilled the the the tone and
and the the storytelling definitely I
think the um that that limitation of
placing the entire story on
The Vineyard on the farm if you like in
The Vines
um it made a kind of psychological space
for the character and you know the story
obviously goes to Saint Petersburg and
they smuggled to Amsterdam and all this
but we don't go there we stay on the
farm with Madame Cleco
who never really did she never really
did leave her Vineyard she was afraid
that if she left the vineyard it would
be taken from her by these kind of
vultures that wanted her land and uh one
of the things that's good about it is
that she never knows what's going on off
the farm because that's how what it
would have been at the time period
there's no person to call there's even
letters would have been sketchy so she's
trapped on the farm waiting yes this
kind of uh you know storm overhead and
you know that that's it that's all you
can predict is you know the weather that
day and so it really keeps keeps the
story in the present while creating a
kind of tension
um so I think that that was something
that early on we knew that we had to do
to make the film because it couldn't be
you know I think one of the first
budgets came in at like 19 million and
we're like there's no way that we can
make a film right in this climate uh for
a female driven story for uh that the
tune of 19 million so you know you have
to find creative ways to just get things
made and
um
yeah so that was imperative to the to
the to the making of of this film and we
have an incredible cast we're so lucky
to have uh Tom Sturridge and and Sam
Riley they were our first choice of
casting which rarely happens because you
know
um conflicts of interest with other
projects and stuff but
um we were meant to film a year prior to
the time that we actually filmed and it
got pushed a year so it was it was a few
years in the making I'm always curious
to talk about I like talking about the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together so
how did the film change in the editing
room in ways you didn't expect going in
the scripts when we started was very
focused on uh dates and places and and
chronicling
her journey Madame cleco's Journey
Through the present and
um and then as I said at the beginning
the kind of this kind of kind of cutting
cross-cutting between the pass which is
the relationship with Tom storage the
husband and then the present which is
her relationship going forward making
the champagne or trying to make her
throw champagne and with her Mentor
Louis Bond who's played by Sam Riley
and during the editing process it became
clear really that the the kind of
Vitality of the film or the energy of
the film was cutting between the past
and the present and making making the
film this kind of almost a window into
the inner life of Madame Cleco by
juxtaposing these scenes and these store
the these moments backwards and forwards
and we did when we were filming you know
we were looking for kind of portals
almost between the past and the present
so a lot of the film is about memory so
you
a widow in this house but it's the same
house where she lived with her husband
so there are many moments where she sort
of
triggered by something that happens by
lying on the floor then she remembers
the moment where she lay on the floor
with her husband and they talked about
the vineyard too we use those moments as
Bridges between the past and the present
and I think
in a way because the the house and the
farm the house itself is kind of like
itself you know it's like a it's her
it's like an extension of her and her
psychology so everywhere we filmed in
the present we were sort of trying to
push the past into the same spaces so
that we had these kind of chances to
move between the past and the present
using the house or the corridor or the
office or the doorway or the steps or
the courtyard as a joiner as glue if you
like between the past and present so do
you believe uh that singing to the vines
works
and icing to
to my plants and actually I think
scientifically
uh there have been uh studies that that
singing and speaking to your plants
helps them you have to nurture them they
need to be nurtured they need to be sung
too they need and of course well anyway
I wonder though if the people that are
singing to their plans and and it also
those are the same people that are
spending extra time
oh has to be the song
uh and you have to see the movie to hear
the song
so it's a new thing to make your plants
grow I'm a gardener but I'm also quite a
poor singer so I think if I sang to my
person I wouldn't help them so just just
throwing that out there I think you've
got to be a good singer I have found
that the people that that baby their
plans and sing to their plants are also
the ones who are giving extra water and
making sure they're taken care of so I
think that goes hand in hand yeah yeah I
think you know I think the the they
really have you seen what was the film
that was one of my kind of references
one of our references
um it's a French film
Jean de floret that was one of our
Inspirations uh for for the film and do
they sing to the plants in gender for he
he really
he's so passionate about these plants
and and it's so infused by nature and
it's uh again just a metaphor for like
their their their important their babies
they're they're the future they're
regenerative you can chop them down and
they grow back
um and I think that's really beautiful I
think I think the um
The Vines themselves and the when you're
surrounded in that where we filmed near
shably you know the the houses are
surrounded by vines on all sides and
they're sort of you know the landscape
of that part of France is very much you
know it's Wine Country
um and I think we felt when we were kind
of developing and talking about it that
the vines as well yes the old old Vines
spiritual body
if it felt as so that represented their
love story you know because the the
beginning of the story with Francois and
Barb is them trying to create Taste and
to create a certain flavor and you know
differently than the old ways yes kind
of revolutionary with their mindset they
were they they wanted to go against the
old way of doing things that set you
know kind of During the Revolution and I
think that they very much represent the
that that figure of wanting to
do it differently the way that it was
done before and that that was kind of a
part of
of their rebellion in a sense we will
sing to the vines sure
um yeah it's interesting doing
interviews like this a tiff because you
you're talking but you can't really get
into the nuts and bolts of things
because you can't spoil anything yeah
but um before I run out of time with you
uh you guys got to Premiere here at the
Toronto International Film Festival it
is my favorite Fest I love this place
for each of you thank you for being here
despite the strikes and for supporting
independent cinema oh yeah well yes and
all Cinema and you've been here with
director I mean to me this is the best
the best thing about coming to a film
festival is meeting other filmmakers and
regardless of who's here and how sorry
it is and could be we have to celebrate
the filmmaking in the craft 100 is what
I love about being here this year that's
what it's going to say what does it mean
especially for this year to have your
film Premiere here it's massive for us I
mean we are a true independent so this
is an amazing
you know Festival to come to
um and for me it's my first time here I
I've been absolutely
kind of bowled over by the the feeling
in the audiences the they feel very live
it feels um it's almost like being in a
theater it has a a very special mood and
kind of uh atmosphere for all of the
films that I've seen
um you know the audiences are cheering
the producer credits at the beginning
which I've never seen that in any
screenings where they know the previous
Productions by producers and it's just a
really
um a buoyant festival and it feels like
the films get lifted by the audience
which I think is an incredible an
incredible thing especially for a movie
like ours yeah I was going to say on
that note I'm going to let you guys go
and enjoy some of our food and
festivities and
um I really say sincere congratulations
uh I wish you guys nothing but the best
and huge success for the film and um
thank you for coming in thank you you're
always wonderful